Gabe's in Texas hi Gabe how are you
doing well Dave how are you better than
I deserve how can we help awesome to
have a question about student loans it's
a mixture of a mathematics question and
kind of a kind of familial question so
150k total 11k in my name and then the
rest of my parents there was never an
official agreement about like me paying
it off but I've been helping for the
past few years since they're in their
60s and you know gonna be retiring
probably in about a decade or so but
with so much left over I'm wondering
like I've been doing really well myself
saving the past three years do I just
throw all my savings at it and then
aggressively pay it off in the next 18
months which I think I could do or what
do you do for a living yeah I'm a
designer so I'm in tech I make about
1/10 a year I don't good for you how old
are you Gabe 28 or 29 okay so you won't
pay the 7,000 off immediately right I
could do that hoarseness in your name
needs to be done right now you got money
in savings you said how much I have
about 130 total 30% in retirement and
the rest just under 100 is liquid where
do you have it at I'm confused so you
just have you have like 90 thousand
bucks in savings and the savings account
the rest is in retirement is that right
correct okay yeah all right well you
write a check today and pay off the
seven that's not in question that's your
debt and then you've got to decide am I
going to take on this other debt and
treat it like it's mine is that a yes or
a No Gabe it's unclear because it's
under my parents a Parent PLUS I
understand I understand you do not owe
the money legally right right nor will
you ever oh it legally do you want to
pay it do you want to pay it off anyway
I want to help them absolutely I don't
know if I want to pay off the full
amount because basically I'm saving for
a house and a wedding in the next couple
in the next couple of years and if I do
aggressively pay it off I'm basically
hunting all that at least probably for
four or five years down the line noggin
I make 110 grand yeah man and you've
already got you've already almost got
enough to pay it off yeah Gabe what are
your parents saying or are they saying
we want your help or is this something
that you are actually stepping up and
saying I want to help they want us or
they want me to help as much as I can
but it's not on me it's kind of like
whatever I can contribute okay so let's
put a dollar amount on this how much do
you want to give your parents on there
alone I mean I'd like oh by the way I
have been for the past three years
contributing about 650 a month for it
but I feel like if I do that that's
seven thousand dollars a year you're
gonna write a check today and pay off
your 7,000 not alone okay period
that leaves us like eighty something
thousand dollars to work with for the
wedding the house and we're gonna I'm
gonna throw them a chunk and I'm gonna
be done yeah where I'm going to take the
whole thing on and I'm gonna knock it
out really really fast with your
fabulous income because that's where
your 90 grand came from you've been
saving like a maniac and instead I'm
gonna pay debt like a maniac if you're
taking this on so how much of the
hundred and forty-three thousand that is
remaining are you going to pay what they
have okay seventy thousand bucks I would
write them a check today dime good now
you got nothing hanging over your head
anywhere you make a hundred and ten
thousand use the same intensity that
you've been using on all these other
issues to build up your wedding fund in
your house fund okay right and that did
not cost you four years it cost you
about a year Yeah right how quick you're
gonna put 70 grand back if you have no
bills at all making 110 as a single dude
yeah yeah I could do it in under two
years there you go - yeah you could do
it in eighteen months or one year
absolutely you know if you had to okay
so right if I'm you I want to get the
same mom and dad I'm willing to pay half
for this and I'm just gonna do it today
and the rest of its gonna be on you and
I'm gonna feel zero guilt about it
okay
yeah that makes them and then that that
sets you free from whatever moral
obligation you felt like you had you
obviously have no legal obligation and
you don't even have a handshake
obligation you just want to help mom and
dad so they're not stung and stuck and
then they're gonna have to step up and
knock out the other 70 agreed agreed
yeah just for the past few years it's
kind of I just felt in-between I get it
yeah the unknown is what's killing this
deal for me right you know this is
Rainer get off the ladder thing and make
a decision and that that clarity then
and the cleanliness of that clarity is
going to help the relationship with them
then they know what you're gonna do so
they know what they got to do yeah it's
good for them too yeah so good stuff man
it's you're a good man to step up and do
that that's very cool
dad write those checks and then I'd
rebuild that savings